every morning Alejandra Rodriguez
Bautista follows and her ancestors
footsteps she goes to the agave plants
behind her house the juice they yield
can be turned into pokey a Mexican drink
that's been made in the country for
centuries it's also her primary source
of income is the loss costumbre schemes
here I'm rescuing the traditions my
parents passed on to us they only saw
their pulque in the local area but I
hope to bring it to the cities to people
have heard of polka but they don't
really know much about it and if I tell
them about its benefits I'll be able to
sell more lubricants a year based on
taste clean things like Alejandra most
of the nearly 200 residents of El
Emerson earn a living making polka
it's hard work for not much money many
dream of one day having a better life in
the big cities of Mexico or in the u.s.
most of the villages young people have
already left Alejandra's three children
no longer live here either she herself
had moved to Mexico City but had to
return to look after her parents and
continued their tradition of polka
production
because of emigration many forms in the
region are suffering from neglect I'm a
son is located at an elevation of over
two and a half thousand meters when it
rains water runs into the valley as a
result soil erosion has become an
increasingly grave problem in recent
years it makes it really hard to grow
maize wheat and beans and these crops
are central to the diet of most people
here if we lose the soil it will be
really difficult to regenerate it mental
I will miss her it's a vicious circle as
the erosion grows worse even more young
people leave
that's why Bibiana Bautista Gaytan set
up the mujeres Millonarios group they're
combating erosion by planting something
that flourishes here agave planted and
Rose the agave roots form a network that
helps keep water and nutrients in the
soil the hope is that fertile farmland
will persuade the villages young people
to come back
we want to motivate the young people to
take care of our homeland and our soil
and above all we want to give them an
incentive to stay here we don't want
them to leave her group has also been
getting support from Mexico City
Emiliano
Ettore Agha is a born-and-bred city
dweller his life is a world away from
Emison but he saw a lot of Mexico's
rural areas as a child on family
vacations that wants to raise awareness
of the problems facing people there in
2017 he founded a startup called route
Opia which organizes sustainable trips
to the rural Outback but many other eco
tourism operators he says aren't as
sustainable as they'd like to claim the
tourism in Mexico has to change because
right now
of it it's still based on an extractive
system and this means that we are people
are using the natural and cultural
capital of communities and all freedoms
without giving back to the system
his company offers an alternative the
trips that organizes aim to treat the
rural population as equal partners most
in the proceeds stay in those
communities the money is reinvested on
the ground for example in environmental
protection projects like the one run by
the mujeres Milan arias the fair tourism
system also takes group bookings these
visitors are off to LMS and today
they're accompanied by a number of Ruto
pious staff who serve as intermediaries
between the tourists and local residents
after a seven-hour drive they finally
arrive an lms on the communication is
not as fluid as a beginning and this is
because there's a huge cultural gap
sometimes there's even big language
barriers if there's a true sense of
being welcomed to a community then that
gap goes fades away quickly lms in that
cultural gap is also closed by sharing a
bowl of pokey the beverage made from
fermented agave its production has a
proud tradition in Mexico going back
more than a thousand years that's a
refreshing slightly sour taste
it's viscous consistency also takes some
getting used to
in Mexico agave plants are also known as
maguey they take 5 10 or more years to
grow to maturity the pork arrows then
hold a ceremony in which they ask God
for permission to open the plant every
day for an entire year
this maguey will now yield several
leaders of agua yet this honey water is
then fermented for several days to
produce its characteristic flavor
the result is poking also known as the
Aztec drink of the gods as the Sun sets
the visitors joined the locals around a
campfire conversation flows and grows
more relaxed the reticence of this
morning starts to melt away the next
morning Alejandra offers a short class
in the mystical language the tourists
are an asset for LMS and she says and
not just in the financial sense the
villagers are too poor to travel
elsewhere but they're happy to meet
young visitors from across Mexico see
Camille and then since this trip has
made me ask myself a lot of new
questions when I talk to the people here
they show me an area that is completely
unknown if you come from the city with
no Canosa squanders pointless I loved it
getting to know this other side of my
country's culture it's been a
life-changing experience the visitors
will spend another two days here but
before they leave the villagers invite
them to come back in a few months the
timing is no coincidence that's when
locals will be hosting a big Polka
festival here and I'm a son
you